in corona times body language is harder
to read but behind the mask
the uk israeli bombed is strong this is
dominic rabb's first visit here as
foreign secretary
and it comes at a potential moment of
inflection in the long struggle for
peace
and equality between israel and the
palestinians
we are big supporters and welcome the
agreement for normalization of relations
with the uae
this is a very positive step and with it
of course
which is very important the suspension
of
annexation
[Applause]
the agreement by the united arab
emirates to formally recognize israel
moved the dial in this struggle
palestinians saw it as a dagger in their
back the uk
sees the geopolitical merits in the deal
and now hopes to bring the palestinians
back to the table
but while donald trump's peace plan
remains on that table with less land for
the palestinians with no removal of
israeli settlements
but with no capital in east jerusalem
for a future state of palestine
there is complete deadlock from
jerusalem the british motorcade passed
israel's security wall and those israeli
settlements
into the west bank to ramallah to meet
the palestinian leadership
the uk has good relations with the
palestinians
abbas is a president without a state a
man who
for all the sympathy for the palestinian
cause is struggling to stay relevant
the signs of this long struggle and the
illusions of progress
are all around the reality though is a
long stalemate one in which the
palestinians
always lose the alternative argue
pragmatists
is for the palestinians now to engage
not to agree
with any part of donald trump's peace
plan but to come to the table to
talk to put forward something fresh
something new
mustafa baguti is a veteran palestinian
politician
we never refuse to negotiate what they
want us to do
is to surrender to a plan that
discriminates against
us before we negotiate and then they
call it negotiations
the israelis and the americans want the
palestinians to come all the way to
their position
that won't happen marc stone sky news in
ramallah